wie oder was geht ab und herzlichen zu
einer runde sky bzw
schreibers und reallife fragen
beantworten ich werde jetzt den ersten
hälfte vom video circa hälfte zu spielen
und dabei fragen beantworten der zweiten
hälfte werde ich so fragen beantworten
weil ihr nicht so wirklich wusste ob ich
ein lila viele machen oder nicht das war
ich habe auch total gefragt und jemand
erst mal fragen beantworten und dann
müsst ihr aber nicht haye der die ganze
zeit fragen beantworten sondern nur ein
bisschen fragen beantworten zu erste
frage herr staeck silber kleber warum
nennen alle youtuber in letzter zeit
ihre fragen sie ihre fragen rund um so
komisch ich weiß es nicht ich weiß nur
dass ich das schon länger mache ich bin
ein echter trendsetter was das angeht
muss ich sagen und ich finde es sehr
fraglich und gemeint dass alle das jetzt
auch machen nein ich wirklich also ich
hab keine ahnung aber ich mache das auf
jeden fall schon immer dass ich meine
videos so komisch nennen der will mich
runterhauen der will dass sich zickzack
enjoy aber in chengdu erst mal pink
silber kleber da hab ich das video
beenden
das fängt gerade erst an der kollege
darf auch unter den hier runter
wahrscheinlich okay wir sind noch zwei
spiele wenn man erstmal ein paar
schnelle fragen weil sonst wird es doch
etwas kürzer als ich eigentlich
angedacht hat hast du dieses jahr noch
eine größere reise geplant
eigentlich nicht ist ja auch relativ
bald schon rum das jahr und eigentlich
muss ich sagen habe ich da nichts
geplant nicht der mensch sieht nichts
wenn man sieht seine okay man sieht sein
blöcke nicht irgendwelche vorsätze für
das jahr 2016
ich halte von vorsätzen nichts man
sollte dinge auch so schaffen können
auch ohne vorsätze denke ich zumindest
werde es nun aber ich hatte mir
abschieden den fall fürs schienennetz
das wäre dadurch jetzt kommen wir unter
mein freund kommt wenn es nur ein
oh gott ich habe hoch was ist ein tipp
gegen langeweile bei sky wars
runterfallen und doch stellen
okay das ist ein bisschen kürzer
ausgefallen als ich dachte die runde war
insgesamt wieder kurz
okay das war jetzt etwas kurz und ich
war schlecht aber bei einem rila video
kann man nichts falsch machen deshalb
werde ich jetzt noch mal schnell ein
paar fragen beantworten
herzlich willkommen zur idee ich ziehe
mir die swak kapuze auf und los geht's
xaver kleber welche youtuber guckst du
noch so
ich gucke hauptsächlich casinos at
ansonsten gucke ich mich immer so ein
bisschen rum teilst du mich aufzuregen
wie viel scheiße manche leute hochladen
teils weil ich tatsächlich interessant
finde aber regelmäßig schauen tue ich
vor allem casey hätte ich selber kleber
was würdest du gott sagen wenn er dich
plötzlich anruft oder was für fächer
hättest du heute in klammern montag in
der schule
ich hatte eine doppelstunde deutschland
eine doppelstunde italiener stand eine
doppelstunde englisch dann eine
doppelstunde projekte ende doppelstunde
wissenschaftlich gruppe deutsches fix
seminare sagt euren eltern nicht als ich
so rede in meinen videos ja also bis 17
uhr 30 war es insgesamt das war mir zu
lang persönlich aber leider muss sieht
es trotzdem machen wäsche selber lieber
was ist dein tipp gegen langeweile das
internet hast du schon mal einen
austausch gemacht wenn ja wie findest du
es bin nämlich am überlegen ein zu
machen ich muss sagen ich habe austausch
gemacht und es war eine richtig richtig
coole erfahrung also einfach die neue
kultur die neue umgebung quasi von ja
den diener freund freundeskreise
freundschaften und so weiter und so fort
all das ist echt eine sehr coole erleben
und ich finde das macht ein irgendwie
auch ein stück reifer ich meine ein
austausch du bist in einem neuen umfeld
gehasst eine komplett neue andere
sprache sag ich mal die noch nicht
beherrscht und musste ich da ein finde
ich finde es ist echt war für mich eine
wichtige erfahrung insofern ich sagen ja
mach das ich hatte natürlich das glück
ich hatte einen megacoolen
austauschpartner grüße an francesco an
dieser stelle dann habe ich deshalb von
anfang an sehr wohl gefühlt
das kann natürlich auch anders sein aber
an sich ist eine coole erfahrung und
sollte man machen hashtag silber kleber
hast du jetzt nach dem was in paris
passiert ist angst auf den
weihnachtsmarkt oder zuzugehen nein
sollte man auf keinen fall weil allein
ich meine es schrecklich was passiert
ist aber die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
einem selbst was passiert bei einer
solchen sache ist wirklich minimal wenn
man
prozentual betrachtet wie viele leute
wie die leute opfer von einem
terroranschlag werden in europa dann ist
das wirklich ein ganz ganz kleiner
anteil ist macht das natürlich nicht
minder schlimm was passiert aber es ist
unwahrscheinlich dass an was passiert
und zweitens sollte man auch keine angst
haben weil sonst hätten die leute die
terroranschläge verüben bzw
die organisationen erfolg und das sollte
man auf keinen fall bewerkstelligen oder
garantieren dass sie erfolg haben
insofern nein ich habe keine angst und
so ist das auch
hättest du gerne ein haustier ich muss
sagen nein nicht wirklich ist nicht so
dass ich keine tiere mag oder so aber
das ist einfach so viel verantwortung
die ich nicht brauche
also ich bin mit meinen menschen zu
frieden und sicherheit es reize ein tier
zu haben aber wenn dann wäre es
wahrscheinlich noch im rund von den
eigenschaften er aber mit hunden bin ich
nicht so 100 prozent gut weil ich mal
einer gewissen hat und insofern ein ich
habe kein haus kein haustier und ich
befürchte dieses video ist ziemlich kurz
geworden aber es war auch ziemlich
lustig heißt es ich weiß es nicht
ja bis morgen